Superheroes stick together.
In the aftermath of Sony and Disney failing
to come to an agreement to renegotiate terms
of its deal that allowed Tom Holland's Spider-Man
to be a part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
Deadpool actor Ryan Reynolds came forward
to address the situation.
Reynolds' response to Spider-Man swinging
out of the MCU was witty as all get-out - which
is to be expected when dealing with the actor
whose tongue is firmly planted in his cheek
- but it sadly offered fans little comfort
in this tumultuous time.
Twitter user @ChaoticKing_ was one of many
fans who turned to Reynolds to help save Spider-Man,
or at least give them a bit of solace after
having their Spidey-loving hearts shattered.
Clearly hoping for a silver lining in all
the darkness, @ChaoticKing_ asked Reynolds
on Twitter whether Spider-Man's MCU exit could
eventually result in a team-up movie with
Spider-Man and Deadpool.
Reynolds gave a half-humorous, half-heartbreaking
response:
"You can.
But you can only see it in my heart."
If fans weren't sufficiently devastated over
the news that Holland's web-slinging vigilante
won't be able to play on the Marvel Studios
playground anymore, Reynolds' tweet absolutely
crushed them.
One fan tweeted at Reynolds,
"That's literally not the response we wanted.
We wanted a yes.
A big, fat yes.
Please and thank you."
Another fan begged the actor,
"Ryan pls help us."
Clearly, sorrowful Spider-Man fans are placing
a lot of stock in Reynolds' ability to either
roll up his sleeves and duke it out with Sony
executives himself, or do some sort of behind-the-scenes
string-pulling to get Spider-Man back into
Marvel's movie realm.
"Yeah, it's me, Deadpool, and I got an offer
that you can't refuse!"
As much as we love Reynolds - and as cool
as it would be to see his raunchy, hard-R-rated
superhero film series collide with Spider-Man's
world - it's strange that so many people are
wanting him to do something about the Sony-Disney
split.
Granted, Deadpool is a Marvel Comics character
that Marvel Studios hasn't yet been able to
use in the MCU due to rights restrictions
- which is a fate that Spider-Man had suffered
up until 2015, when Disney and Sony struck
a deal to let Holland's hero character appear
in Marvel movies while Sony retained financial,
distribution, and creative control.
But there's a lot more at play here, and there's
basically nothing that Reynolds can do to
change things.
While Reynolds is one of a few actors who
can commiserate with Holland about playing
a Marvel character that isn't allowed in the
MCU, there's a high probability that Reynolds'
Deadpool actually will join the MCU in the
future.
After Disney bought the majority of 20th Century
Fox's assets in a $71.3 billion deal earlier
this year, the House of Mouse acquired a bunch
of Marvel Comics characters whose screen rights
resided at Fox.
Deadpool is one of them - and while nothing
has been confirmed by the way of a third Deadpool
movie or Wade Wilson's forthcoming inclusion
in the MCU, it seems fairly inevitable.
The Merc with a Mouth made big money at the
box office and has helped revolutionize the
superhero genre - sparking studio executives
to consider giving darker, grittier, and more
violent characters their own franchises.
Plainly put, Disney and Marvel would be fools
not to induct Deadpool into the MCU.
Regardless if that ends up happening, and
even if Reynolds never slips back into the
red-and-black suit for another Deadpool movie,
Deadpool is property of Marvel Studios.
Spider-Man isn't.
And now that Sony and Disney have done the
corporate equivalent of filing for divorce,
it's virtually impossible for a Deadpool-Spider-Man
team-up movie to happen.
Reynolds may have a ton of clout in Hollywood
and an unmatched presence on social media,
but one thing he doesn't have is the power
to squash the beef between two of the biggest
entertainment companies in the world.
Wish as we might that it wasn't so, Peter
Parker and Wade Wilson probably won't ever
meet.
Like Reynolds, fans will simply have to keep
that dream alive in their hearts.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.